all right so all the fans who couldn't
make it out to Florida sure came
together to show their support here at
home several watch parties were held
across the valley today and people just
really went all out Sasha loft is at one
of them joining us now live from
downtown Summerlin with more on really a
massive event held there tonight with
loyal fans
Denise and Brian it was or the knights
rather were in Florida tonight but the
party was here in Las Vegas now those we
spoke with who came here to downtown
Summerlin for that party earlier tonight
say they're not going to let tonight's
loss get them down they're already
looking forward to game four go nice go
a community coming together for a common
cause
everyone hoping and praying for the
golden knights to bring the Stanley Cup
home this is our year okay Downtown
Summerlin was packed with thousands of
fans and their families all cheering for
our team
and even though the vgk lost game three
those here said they're more than
optimistic as they show their support
from afar did they just play so well
together they're so deep and they're fun
to watch it's exciting Haley harzinski
senior marketing director of downtown
Summerlin says her team is happy to host
and events like this help them show
their appreciation for everything the
knights have brought to our city I think
the entire Las Vegas Community is
thrilled you know we're thrilled at
downtown Summerlin at the Howard Hughes
Corporation just to have the nights in
our backyard this as we inch closer to
potentially winning it all
I'm looking forward to that parade I
think that would be amazing
now there are a few more watch parties
planned for game four on Saturday here
in Las Vegas one is actually on Water
Street in Henderson another at the Las
Vegas ballpark here in downtown
Summerlin of course puck drop at five
o'clock again and we have more
information on those locations on our
website 8newsnow.com reporting live
tonight Sasha Loftus 8 News Now